here's hello chars their goals
today I have the
opportunity to discuss with charlène
[Music]
who speaks who is therefore quadrilingual
it's the expression it's nice
French Spanish English
Japanese
here is who unleashed youtube which is
called we feel that there quite
good is first of all first question
how come you speak 4
so for me already I am French my
mother tongue selle français and
throughout my schooling  necessarily in
France I learned English like
everyone else but I really wanted to
push the learning a little bit because
for me it was not enough so I was
always looking for
interesting content I translated  songs
when i was little hungry i was
really into learning the
language
yes and suddenly when i was 18 i
wanted to learn another language and i
went to spain in barcelona where
i am now and  i left in
esp  agne without really knowing how to speak
Spanish because I had absolutely
not studied the language
I learned on the job really here in
the street as you can say and then
I stayed for eight years and then
I left for Japan for almost
three and a half years to work
as a teacher is the same I
knew absolutely nothing of the language
everything practically from a fan
Japanese Spanish anyway the momentum that I
learned a little bit as an adult
this  are languages that I learned in th
country without having gone to language courses in th
country itself so that's why I spe
k if four languages that's good but go
d in the case of Spanish
ery far from French  no his
is braids is very close it's true
but still
so it's a question what two
hours of meeting people from one in
the street when will stay in shops
or are there still des
trips the activities even without
going short and  feature films
you did specific things
what was the strategy
for learning Spanish first
and then already almost okay then
strategy I don't know if we
can call it strategy because at that
time I  didn't have any but yes i
tried to meet a lot
of spanish speakers a lot a lot i
lived with a family that was half
swiss half spanish but spoke a
lot of french at home so it
wasn't really the place
i was  I was going to learn a lot but it's
true that I knew a lot of Spanish
so I learned a lot at that time
I had a Spanish boyfriend something
that helps a lot
you have to say what is suddenly
so yes I learned a lot of Spanish
really like that
by listening and imitating finally
I did anyway like when I was a
child finally limited and I spoke
then I learned Spanish at
the  university and grammar
phonetics india t  out and that's where
I honed let's say the level
is that you'll get a lot of it yeah
I read a lot I read a lot
that's what I'm saying I got a lot I
read a lot of articles d  press articles
even if I did not understand
exactly 100% of the article
was not serious for me it was
important to stay a little bit stay
connected and so yes I read a lot
of articles is what I  was doing is
that I like music a lot so I
was always very interested in
song lyrics and so I was reading
the lyrics of songs that I was listening to
and that actually allowed me to learn a
lot a lot of  words
in spanish at that time is that
you were watching television yeah also
it's true it's true that time it's
true that at that time I watched a lot of
tv and it's true that that  it helped me a
lot it's true yeah it's
true it's been a lot of football
yes it's true that now that I
remember there is  very long ago more
than 15 years ago but it's true that
now I remember I had a
lot of Spanish constantly in my
ears which I lived in barcelona
necessarily it was easy in ten 10 years
but it's  with we I listened to
the radio a lot the radio - part in the TV
I also read newspapers I read
the lyrics of songs I was enough I
wanted to immerse myself a little bit in
the culture it's true yes it's good
in my body also for example I have
when I was a student change traveling
to thousands millions of m wow I was
talking all about it talking all in one with
a day near the round the cisr talking it
helps enormously
even if we are wrong because  we learn yes
but by going from French to Spanish
it's easy yeah it's now
how it happened with Japanese
with Japanese
I arrived I said to osaka and
to osaka
I arrived really without knowing
finally I spoke three Thursday and three
words what I have  I'm going to be a little a
little introduction to a school just
to learn a few words quickly
it was maybe 3:02 p.m. Japanese so
it was really nothing and I arrived
I'm looking for a job straight away
I got some
I didn't really have  need Japanese
in my work so it was
quite a chaotic slow learning I
will say but effective because after
some time I was I was
completely able to have
discussions with people of course
my level 2 gn  is not perfect that's for
sure I know it is not
yes but not perfect but
communication is possible and for me
the purpose of a language is
really communication so even if I
make mistakes it doesn't matter  I know that people
understand me and I know that I can
refine that I don't currently have it I
take online Japanese lessons
once a week and sat sat it
brings me to me it brings me to ask myself questions
questions and it helps me a lot  p
in fact to refine my grandmother and
I regret a little not having
done it sooner finally but yeah
yeah ok and now what is your
activity will test our channel instead of the
web and teach you yes then he
added yes  I am I am an
online French teacher so I teach
French and also Spanish online
I have a website called
bonjour bcn point like on which ge
explains a little bit what I do and
therefore c  is my main activity I
am a teacher in vines from
barcelona will inherit all the details of a
yeah in the info bar always at
bars yes and she in teaching
one of the questions there that here is for me
in learning the  learning
and content as we use because
well I'm not in japan I'm
not in spain
often people appear people
are at home in a country we do
n't speak the language they are in
so learn
the content and  it becomes very
important the content that we can listen to
when we can then often read
things that we can use on the
rails and there are languages like Frenc
Spanish there is a lot of conte
t on the internet there
is  others taking it months but often there are so
of you content for beginners there
is a lot there is little too even
yeah yeah it was
difficult content so authentic bass and s
is limitless
because that there are books there are
any grandiose alteration
anything but often it's there it's the
intermediate level that is missing to
allow people to go things
that have become comfortable because
it's easy because here they already have it
done and then the real authentic too
difficult and those who live that's what's in
between and that's where I even have an
interview is good
authentic French there's nothing a few
entrepreneurs say we  won't give
more names but I interjected them  wé and
who created the things in between yes
and previously is what you
use what resources you use bold
to help for for me in my
work
yes ok then it depends on the level
of course the furrows not of
the intermediary  I use a lot of
authentic documents so we have
online because yes I think you are
right in the sense that there is a
lot of things for beginners but
also a lot of things for
advanced for advanced levels and little
for levels  intermediate but
sometimes in fact I think that
the student and the teacher should also be given a little bit of a girl
face in front of things that are a bit a
bit complicated because if he always stays in
front of things that are too since
too easy or  beginners the student
tends a little to stay a little
how to stay a little yeah to
rest a little on his laurels it
seems in French and suddenly I
think it's important
while accompanying him a  with a lot of
benevolence and we are close to him in pro,
telling him that if there is
something that is not necessarily going well we will help him
I think it is also important to
put him at a certain level from a
certain level of putting it in front of
things a little bit complicated challenges
not video games as a challenge
finally that what I read every
day
yes excuse me a wall of which you
always tell my students that for example
judged the groups months of
twice a week once a week and
sometimes the students do
n't understand a word or two where they tell me
oh there you speak a little fast or there I do
n't understand you and every time I tell them
don't worry don't worry  do
n't worry you'll surely understand
next week or in
two weeks or in three weeks if
you don't understand this month you
'll understand next month
it's total immersion you have to
immerse yourself a little  little in  the language
me when I arrived in japan I
understood absolutely nothing and little by
little I clicked the facts the
connections I followed but that it
meant that and that in fact it is in
this context that I am going  using it
I made a little bit of the connections
like a child would when he's
like he's learning his mother tongue
it's a little bit different
because the brain at that stage is
different but anyway I  think
it's important to use things
sometimes at a slightly higher level
to motivate students
I think about providing justice a lot
of resources there were resources
too that I use that I do myself
but yes I think  that in
authentic documents it is quite
quite possible in any case for
intermediaries
yes I agree also agree with
you that the fact of not compensating does not
matter it does not matter when in  forest
defense and immersion the fact that it
that  you've done the language between good there
are things altogether that it's
still the fact of making mistakes
you must not seek perfection and
that's why you have i against
questions of cooperation
I hate  I understood what I
understood I misunderstood I
agree with you it's true when
Jacques Ange taught French in
Japan to children they were between 3
and 8 9 years old we had
classes in  'total immersion for five hours
in a row an every day and at the beginning
the children three years old and we took
absolutely nothing at all and in fact it is
incredible and wonderful to see like
the child after a few weeks
he's already starting to pick up
something good ok it's 10 o'clock now she
told me to go to the bathroom
ok I can see that deezer you have to go to the
bathroom toilet that means that and
it was great
it's incredible  the brain it is
incredible and I think that the adult is
capable of oddo cie to do that don  c me I
speak a lot a lot the language in
my in my classes if it's
French classes I only speak French it
's Spanish classes I only
speak Spanish is of course I adapt to I
'm going  not speak like a native I accept
of course but I really believe in I
really believe that total immersion
and being a little lost
sometimes it helps it's the student yes I
agree and the  amount of content
that must be consumed
not these photos nor my side it is
unlimited but when the king of libya
among themselves the similar system by
the time me I find nothing I do not
recommend it personally no no
but they say with I  book there you
will reach a b2 level nantes
angers which will not be wrong the info you have to
read the field game we have statistics to
read I know how many millions of mont
jolie in Russian how many thousands
of gold I have listened to  it sees so
much content for the brain to learn
when you said the  brain
only can only take
exactly takes a lot a lot of
friends so that this quarter is so
completely its infinite and it's super
interesting really great with
now the podcasts that left an
incredible anyway everything we
can listen to every day but
unfortunately often the podcasts they
don't have a transcription train years that
that's yeah that's true that's
a bit there that's true that's a shame
that's a shame  it's true me ok here and
and in spanish and catalan catalan
therefore if the enveloped renoleau no
love algeria to that opposing tender
correctly departure a few tears
mucho tiempo vivaki father unemployed
castilian go to his expectations
ok if it's  is the right important decision
happened to whom this super important and
its six prefaces he knew this by a
personal French honor it
fights to erase the first the
parquet separate room princess anne
spanish as well as an italian ordos no
it is in these times then if you have
nancy cared believe that their
total morning if if it is exact it is
practical and the cftc she called back
difficult
clara clara clara on the roofs of paris
has no one to  qena at the far
post according to the police does not use nor mona
reference ian schultz and the dresses
they have french knew about
science these boxes not easy if j if
the league the as saint etienne here
although separated are  of course here are already
fifteen minutes it goes quickly
if there is one thing for sure interesting
isn't it thank you very much at the time
here thank you very much estimate hello
hello
[Music]